wenn es einen gegenstand gibt der quasi
immer in deiner nähe ist dann ist es
höchstwahrscheinlich dein smartphone
abgesehen vom duschen haben
wahrscheinlich die meisten von uns unser
handy immer griffbereit über 70 von uns
sogar während wir schlafen
gleichzeitig finden viele unserer
gedankengänge in unserem smartphone
statt wir google in fragen die uns
gerade interessieren speichern wichtige
termine ab und sogar ein signifikanter
anteil unserer zwischenmenschlichen
beziehungen findet inzwischen auf diesem
stück glas statt
manche experten gehen sogar soweit das
smartphone als erweiterung des gehirns
zu bezeichnen
ich meine weißt du noch wo du am 29 märz
2014 warst das smartphone weiß es
wahrscheinlich algorithmen kennen dich
inzwischen besser als deine engsten
freunde und es sind genau diese
algorithmen die dich tagtäglich
manipulieren und vielleicht sogar für
donald trump verantwortlich sind
aber fangen wir erst mal ganz von vorne
an
[Musik]
jede sekunde werden im internet 8700 25
tweets gesendet 951 bilder auf instagram
gepostet und acht minuten videomaterial
hier auf youtube hochgeladen
eine erstaunliche menge content wird
heutzutage von uns für uns produziert
dauerhaft und rund um die uhr
früher wurde das programm im fernsehen
und im radio von den sendern entschieden
und die einzige entscheidung die man
selber treffen konnte wat den sender zu
wechseln
aber heutzutage übernehmen diesen
auswahlprozess algorithmen der berühmt
berüchtigte youtube algorithmus der
darüber entscheidet welche videos viele
klicks bekommen und welche nicht ist
aber nur einer von vielen
auf jeder großen plattform wurde
irgendwann die entscheidung getroffen
die inhalte nicht mehr
chronologisch nach upload zeit
anzuzeigen sondern nach relevanz und
selbst google muss eine millionen
suchergebnisse filtern und die
relevantesten weit oben präsentieren
denn wer geht schon auf die zweite seite
von google
um entscheiden zu können was relevant
und wichtig für dich ist müssen die
algorithmen natürlich erst einmal wissen
wer du bist alles was einen auszeichnet
als person
das ist sandra maz sie ist computational
social science ist es ist dem professor
an der columbia business school in new
york und expertin für das sogenannte
psychological targeting also es geht im
endeffekt darum dass man so
charaktereigenschaften von personen
vorher sagen möchte oder und das sind
jacob vom kanal breaking up und ich und
wir durften sandra ein paar spannende
fragen zu ihrer forschung stellen bisher
alles was wir uns angeschaut haben von
persönlichkeit deshalb extra version
aber auch wie gewissenhaft ist man wie
sozial ist man erotisch ist man über
lebenszufriedenheit intelligenz
politische orientierung sexuelle
orientierung werte also was hat man ein
wertesystem computer kennt dich
eigentlich besser als alle möglichen
leute in meinem umfeld und potenziell
gesetzt übrigens ein bestimmtes beispiel
häufiger das total spannend finde und
zwar gibt es bestimmte worte die auf
bestimmte charaktereigenschaften
anschließen das bestimmt hat es ist eine
leine von den wirklich eindrücklichen
forschungsergebnissen wo wir uns
anschauen wie sind bestimmte
persönlichkeitseigenschaften also wie
extra versionen der tourismus in
verträglichkeit wie hängen die zusammen
mit den wörtern die man auf der ispo
verwenden
das heißt wenn man sich anschauen würden
bei sprechen extrovertierte leute sieht
man das irgendwie war party ist es
wochenende irgendwie feiern freunde und
introvertierten leute reden über lesen
computer anime das heißt man sieht ja
wirklich den unterschied zwischen den
sozialen aktivitäten die die
extrovertierte leute interessiert und
die mehr
sozusagen die ruhigeren ich bin daheim
kann ich selbst machen
von internetinhalten das ist natürlich
nur eine tendenz eine richtung
extrovertierte menschen verhalten sich
nicht immer und überall extrovertiert
genauso wenig wie introvertierte
menschen immer nur introvertiert sind
persönlichkeit ist vom kontext abhängig
und kann sich auch ändern aber als
introvertierter mensch ist es
wahrscheinlicher dass du dich in einer
bestimmten situation introvertiert
verhältst und mit so einer
wahrscheinlichkeit arbeiten auch die
algorithmen die betrachten nämlich
hunderttausende oder sogar millionen
menschen gleichzeitig und versuchen
aussagen zu treffen die für möglichst
viele dieser personen gelten
es ist also quasi eine aussage über den
durchschnitt die hier getroffen wird
menschen die gerne bücher lesen sind
durchschnittlich eher introvertierte
menschen
das gilt aber noch lange nicht für die
einzelne person und es kann sehr gut
sein dass eine person falsch eingeordnet
wird
das ist in vielen fällen harmlos ein
großer aspekt für den das zeigt logical
targeting wichtig ist ist werbung
zielgerichteter man werbung einsetzen
kann desto effektiver ist sie welche
produkte würden ihr extrovertierte
menschen kaufen und wie muss ich diese
menschen ansprechen wenn sich hier der
algorithmus einmal vertut man ist das
halb so wild
aber wenn wir uns dann mal überlegen das
ist irgendwie dazu führen könnte dass
einen algorithmus vorhersagen macht ob
der kredit aufnehmen kannst aber nicht
im oktober kommt oder nicht ob du als
terrorist eingestuft ist oder nicht
da sind die folgen von fehlern in der
vorhersage viel viel größer
das heißt da wenn man es wirklich
überlegt was es der den bereichen fehler
bereich den wir in unseren algorithmen
haben ist wirklich einen skoda von
context man es nicht haben
das sind beispiele von situationen in
denen der algorithmus versagt aber auch
wenn ein algorithmus perfekt
funktioniert kann er für niedere zwecke
eingesetzt werden
so hat die agentur cambridge analytik
hat daten von über 50 millionen
amerikanern auf facebook gesammelt
im us-wahlkampf 2016 hat donald trump
dann eine menge geld dafür ausgegeben
diese wähler von sich zu überzeugen
dabei wurden menschen gezielt
manipuliert teilweise in dem ihre
persönlichen ängste ausgenutzt wurden
und das alles ohne dass diese menschen
darüber bescheid wussten ob das wirklich
zum wahlsieg für trump geführt hat oder
nicht darüber streiten sich die experten
heute noch das wahlergebnis war sehr
knapp sagen die einen
der einfluss von facebook und zeigte
logical targeting ist recht schwach
sagen die anderen
aber es zeigt was alles möglich ist und
in welche richtung sich meinungsmache
bewegt was eine aussage getroffen
ich fand ich ziemlich krass was gesagt
jede person in seinem privaten umfeld
auch freunde oder familie kennen dich
nicht so gut wieder ein smartphone oder
deinen computer abgesehen von einer
person
westers leider ist es nicht mal meine
forschung ist von von meinem kollegen es
wirklich richtig interessante forschung
ist sie sich angeschaut hat wie gut kann
der computer deine persönlichkeit
vorhersagen von facebook likes und wie
gut sind leute in unserem umfeld in
unseren persönlichkeit vorhersagen und
der 1
die einzige person die tatsächlich den
computer damals 2015 ausgesprochen hat
war der partner
wenn man davon ausgeht dass mittlerweile
die leute noch viel mehr daten haben aus
unterschiedlichen quellen wäre meine
vorhersage dass mittlerweile der
computer auch besser sein partner und
stellt euch jetzt mal vor wie es erst in
zehn jahren aussieht wenn wir alle 24
stunden am tag smart watches tragen die
unseren puls und blutzuckerspiegel
messen oder brillen oder vielleicht
sogar kontaktlinsen mit kameras tragen
die nicht nur wissen wo wir sind sondern
auch was wir gerade sehen ein ziemlich
düsteres bild
deswegen habe ich sandra mal gefragt was
man dagegen tun kann
wenn man sich facebook anschaut das ist
gibt es ganz wenige leute die ihre
privatsphäre settings ändern
das heißt es gibt immer diesen aufschrei
wir uns dass privatsphäre so wichtig und
wenn man sich dann anschaut was leute
tatsächlich machen gibt es total viele
schritte die man selbst in der hand hat
mein paradebeispiel sich alle 911 er ist
ein mal zu gucken wenn man eine app
downloaden
was für daten sammeln will wenn ich
irgendwie eine kalender herunterladen
und liebe meine bilder die will man
location und die will sozusagen in
microphone tappen keine so gute idee
weil die er braucht vermutlich nicht ich
glaube es ist wirklich eine der punkte
wo man richtig viel selbst mehr hand hat
und nicht genug darüber nachdenken wie
ist das bei euch ist es wichtig was mit
ihren daten passiert und habt ihr mal
einen blick auf eure privatsphäre
einstellungen geworfen
dazu habe ich euch hier oben mal eine
umfrage erstellt und mich würde sehr
interessieren wieso die typischen doktor
watson zuschauer bei dem thema
entscheiden
in der arte doku meeting snowden könnt
ihr noch mehr darüber erfahren was man
alles über euch weiß der whistleblower
hat 2013 die überwachung der
amerikanischen regierung auffliegen
lassen und spricht in dieser doku über
seine geschichte und die zukunft der
demokratie im überwachungsstaat dieses
video wurde unterstützt von humanity tv
das ist eine plattform auf der man sich
außerordentliche dokumentarfilme wie zum
beispiel meeting snowden im abo
anschauen kann
neben meetings noten gibt es auch dokus
über wikileaks über china die raumfahrt
die zukunft und auch ganz vieles mehr
und mit dem ersten link in der video
beschreibung könnt ihr euch kostenlos
eine woche lang alle dokumentarfilme auf
humanity tv ansehen
damit unterstützt hier nicht nur um
einen kanal ihr werdet dabei auch etwas
schlauer
in diesem sinne vielen dank fürs
zuschauen und wie immer bleibt neugierig
[Musik]